(rap music)
(introspective piano music)
(crowd cheering)
(record scratching)
- [Gary] But you
need a grounded
practical engine
to this machine.
- [Man] Thank you.
- [Gary] I always knew
I wanted to do shit like this.
So you know what I did about it?
I didn't do any of it for the
first 15 years of my life.
- [Man] Wow, I didn't
think about that.
- [Gary] Go figure, right?
Like...
- [Man] That's incredible.
- [Gary] Like,
yeah that's my actions.
Like, I always had this in me.
I just knew that what the
fuck was I gonna do at 22,
just saying this
is what I want to do.
What the fuck does that mean?
- [Man 2] So,
we're talking to Thad.
This is in my inbox to
yours, and it's about his
daughter, Olivia,
who's nine years old.
She's gonna sit in on it all.
She might not say anything,
but she was able to overcome,
you know, a problem with
bullying because of a video.
(phone ringing)
- [Thad] Hello?
- Thad, it's GaryVee,
how are you?
- [Thad] I'm alright Gary,
it's nice to speak to you.
- Hey Olivia.
- [Thad] Say hello,
come on sweetie.
- [Olivia] Hello.
- So, Thad, from you as
a parent, when did you even
think I want to
share this with Olivia?
- [Thad] It was you
making that point of not
caring about what
other people think of you.
- I am tired of
people not starting
and living their life
on one very simple thing,
which is they're worried
about what other people think.
- [Thad] If Gary feels that
this is an important enough
subject cause it's
happened to so many people,
and it's happened
to him, then I wanted
her to be comfortable
with knowing that
this is quite common,
it happens to everyone,
but there are people
out there who are prepared
to sort of say,
enough is enough.
We want to
support you through this,
because the biggest
problem is, you know,
they don't matter,
and you're actually
holding yourself back.
So that was the message from
us, from my wife and myself,
was you don't worry
about what people think.
But I think having
someone else say it
say it made a big difference.
- [Olivia] Hello.
- [Gary] I just want
to tell you I love you
and thank you for
watching my videos.
- [Olivia] Yes,
thank you as well.
- You're welcome darlin',
have a great day okay?
- [Olivia] Mhmmm.
- Okay, Thad, thank you
so much for sharing this.
- [Thad] No, thank you Gary,
I can't thank you enough.
- I'll talk to you soon.
- [Thad] Keep doing
what you're doing.
- I will, bye bye.
(introspective piano music)
- Hello, how are you?
- [Woman] Hello,
hey, how are you?
Thank you so
much for doing this.
- [Gary] Of course, of course.
- [Woman 2] I'm gonna
get emotional because
I'm just so happy
to have you here.
- [Gary] Thanks, thanks.
- [Woman 2] You're the man.
- [Gary] Awesome, thanks
guys, so check this out.
You guys will like
this, this is a fun thing.
My mom fuckin' lost
her mind this morning.
Alright, go to
your Apple Music app,
just click it, and
then click the browse button
on the bottom middle,
yeah and there I am.
- [Woman] I watched it
this morning (laughing).
- Apple's first show is
called Planet of the Apps,
some of you are
looking at it right now.
It's basically like Shark Tank
and The Voice for apps.
And it was improv
right, it wasn't acting,
and so it was good,
you should watch it.
Now, no I'm just kidding.
(crowd laughing)
- Whatever podcast do
you use so I can do that?
I don't know, how is that?
- People listen to them
when they commute or workout
is the main functionality,
so we're gravitating
towards audio because
we've become multitasking
with second-screen
television watching,
and so now we're
valuing listening to a podcast
and doing our e-mail,
and doing whatever we're doing
over watching the video version.
Voice is growing.
There is incredible
amount of data
we're looking at right now,
that under 30 switching music
listening to podcasting.
That's crazy right?
That's just powerful.
This is what
I love about technology.
You know what technology does?
It brings back history.
What's amazing about
innovation is it just
goes in cycles, so
basically what the mobile device
with like that kind
of capabilities has done
is got us back to
being radio listeners.
Like, there's so
much disruption coming.
It's the same
innovation curve always.
Something gets hyped, everybody
thinks it's gonna happen,
VR, oh my god VR!
VR's fuckin' 20 years away.
The big thing that I wanna
do is get organizations
and people way more
committed to technology
and like changes, and the
place that it's most practical
is in marketing and creative.
And that's why you're
going to see big
companies going to it,
I mean, everybody's
gonna have their moment.
What you're about to see
retail go through over the
next decade is going to
be so carnage, holy shit.
These are real stakes.
Have a great day.
- [Crowd] Thank you.
(crowd applauding)
- [Man 2] Thank you,
thanks for stoppin' by.
- Meet up, meet up,
meet up, meet up, meet up.
- What's your name?
- Victor.
- Victor, nice to meet you.
- Pleasure man, oh my God,
do you know much like,
this is unreal.
- Thank you, man, thank you.
- Fuck.
- I'm running late to a meeting
so let's bang it out real quick.
(muffled chatter)
- Oh my God, thanks.
- Awesome man,
Nice to meet you.
- I wish you the best.
- Thank you, man,
thanks for saying hello.
Okay, so I'm gonna go to this.
- [Iris] Okay,
I'll take the mic.
(slow rap music)
- An hour ago,
on my social media,
I just said come and meet me
at Washington Square Park.
And now we're just gonna
see how many people show up.
(laughs)
("For the World" by Fracx)
- [Tyler] Now
everybody's here, what up?
(crowd cheering)
They should be here in
like eight minutes or so.
- Alright, DRock.
Now it's gonna happen.
(crowd cheering)
(mumbles)
Your books are done?
- Exactly, yeah.
- What's up, vlog?
You know who this is,
#AskGaryvee episode,
clip it right now, DRock, Cha.
My favorite man, right here.
I'm so proud of this guy.
I think too many
people try to figure out
what their niche is
instead of doing shit
and then you
figure it out after time.
Everybody's trying, thank you,
everybody's trying to
figure out shit beforehand.
The answer is to
figure shit out after.
The people you
spend time with are
the ones that
dictate your mindset.
That's it, just 100 percent.
- [Cha] G, I'mma slide.
- I love you.
- [Cha] I love you too, brother.
- Hey, thanks to
sticks, happy to see you all,
thank you all for coming out.
(crowd cheering)
- So, like, vlogging,
you think it's for everyone?
- No, I think
everyone should try it
because if you're documenting
and not creating,
everybody can do it.
I just think that 99 percent
of people aren't interesting.
So I think it's for
everybody worth trying,
'cause the cost
of entry is super low.
I just think most people
don't have anything to say
or aren't doing
anything interesting.
No matter what
you're about to say,
you can't win in
vlogging if it's about
the cool things because you
can't do enough cool things.
You win in vlogging
because you connect with people.
Dude just said,
I don't even fucking know
what you're fucking talking
about, but we connect, right?
So, by the way, but that
doesn't mean you gotta be
high energy and ridiculous
like me, that's just my truth.
You might be
fucking calm as shit
and mundane but
you just might connect.
And a lot of
people just don't know
if they've got the face
or the vibe or the connection
or the story that
connects with other people
and I think it's worth trying.
I figure, based on your vibe,
if you don't do
what you want to do,
you're gonna end
up regretting it,
which is then gonna
manifest at being mad at them
and you are doing
a greater disservice
to the relationship
of you and your parents
by not doing what you want to do
than by doing what
they want you to do.
There's a seed of what
you actually want to do.
You're hiding that seed
'cause you love your
parents so much, right?
- Yes sir.
- You're gonna
then do that and then
you're gonna be 42
and not have the chance
to do your thing and
you're gonna be mad at them
and you're gonna
blame them for it.
And then it's gonna hurt your
relationship, not help it.
I think if it's so
deep inside of you to give,
you need to decide,
you can only give
when you have something to give
and you have stability in that
giving that can be consistent.
So you, I always say, you
have to be selfishly happy
before you worry
about everybody else
because you won't have anything
to give if you're not good.
- You have the
same voice and you're
kind of mentor, a leader,
and I really appreciate
your good intent
and that you try to do
this good thing in business.
It really drives me,
thanks to you,
I started eBay, Amazon.
- [Gary] Yes.
- And right now, designing
t-shirts for merch.
- [Gary] Yes. Yes!
- And I really
love you and, like,
this thing that
you, you're trying
to change the world for better,
it just keeps me
moving forward again.
- [Man 4] Love it.
- That makes me happy.
- [Man 4] That's
love right there.
- I love you.
- Thank you
- Thank you.
- I started out
my summer, I was like
alright, I'm gonna
make music all summer.
But I have not been
able to just get off my ass
and just fucking
make some music.
- [Gary] So what are
you doing instead?
- I've been
watching just Netflix.
(group laughter)
- [Man 5] He's honest,
he's honest.
- [Gary] I love you for that.
- I gotta be honest.
- Honestly, that was the
best part of the whole night,
just that truth is real.
There's a deeper reason,
you know that, right?
- It's--
- It's because you
either don't really
believe in your music or like--
- I'm trying to
perfect it too much.
- The fuck is perfection?
Like, there's just a
lot of bigger reasons
to why you're not doing it.
Perfection's the
disguise of insecurity.
- Yeah.
- You told me, you
said take the leap,
I took the leap, I love you.
I mean that, from
the bottom of my heart.
- [Gary] I love
you too, brother.
- You changed my life.
- [Gary] That makes me
so fucking happy.
- What are you doing?
- [Man 6] I'm
driving to Atlanta
(group laughter)
- Don't fucking drive
and tech, get out of here.
(group laughter)
It means no excuses.
Just spend no time and
energy on how you got there,
just spend all of it on
getting yourself out of there.
It's just time and energy.
Good luck,
alright, I'm out of here.
Yeah, yeah.
Friends, it's GaryVee, listen,
it's like fucking one
o'clock in the morning,
I'm trying to leave,
and this man's like
you can you make a fucking video
for my friends, I'm like fine.
So friends, what's up?
See ya.
(group chatter)
- See ya guys,
good night, thank you.
- [Man 7] Thanks, Gary.
- [Gary] Thank you, good night,
yeah, I got it, thank you.
12:43 in the morning, see ya.
("For the World" by Fracx)